東京に行ったら絶対に行っておきたい10
個のこと一番
友達と遊びたいときは横浜に行くこと東京
は人が多すぎるか2番東京ディズニーシー
に行く事やはり東京といったら東京
ディズニーシーだよね本当は千葉だけどね
3番
かなや方なんでまた来たの好きだから俺の
ことがいや俺のことがでしょは供給でやっ
ておきたいことでまぁそうだけどほんと
東京好きじゃないかでタピオカやっぱり
古くないあじゃあ原宿でホットケーキです
ねもっと古い私の好きな子わけない海違う
音盤静かな所に行きたない時は4
六本木 jils はいやクラブとかそう
いうナイトシーンが苦手私森タワーの夜景
が好きだけどねそれだったら横浜の
ランドマークタワーと六本木ヒルズの
クレープが好きは苺クレープねあクリープ
だとバナナどっちかにしてしながわ水族館
花水族館だったら大阪の方が酔っぱ動作
って推測かってさあ萌えないしねそんな
古いネタを無理やり使わないで中
ノルウェーの人だからねカットの中で2回
もコールバックを使うなよ
うため静かなところに行きたいと言ってい
ないああっ
10番東京は基本的にうるさくてゴミゴミ
してるから落ち着いたおしゃれなところに
行きたいときは首魁やすくランブルスコ会
支部
スクランブル交差点ってこと知らないの
じゃあ渋谷ストリームは
渋谷川ってこと
じゃあここはなにこれどこ宮下港へ
実はした今いいもこうなってるの結構
おしゃれですよねめっちゃ行きたいいい
kuwana
en
anuenue ann
[音楽]
manuale
nande nande